[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Camille christmukkah Fiamma will not
only come
[Music]
since April at least 40 people have been
killed during the protests in Venezuela
many hundreds more have been injured on
the nicolas maduro the president of
Venezuela blames the opposition for the
violin back in 2015 a coalition of
opposition parties won a two-thirds
majority in parliament and since then
Nicolas Maduro uses emergency decrees to
bypass Parliament and many now fear that
their country is turning into a
dictatorship at this point this is
editorship we have no elections
whatsoever those that are were supposed
to be called haven't been called we have
political prisoners everywhere
there is no freedom of speech there is
no separation of power so I mean is this
isn't a dictatorship but then what is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what I want to do is to try to capture
this and what's going on there and and
put into place into images into
beautiful and inspiring images like
sometimes they could reflect rage
sometimes hope some time frustration you
just like documenting what's going on
[Music]
[Music]